be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and today on beyond Omega level we're
gonna be talking about a character that
you guys mentioned in the comments of
The Spectre video that you wanted to see
and they even asked it for for a long
time we're gonna be talking about one of
the most powerful characters in all of
DC Comics Lucifer Morningstar now there
had been several instances of Lucifer
appearing in DC over the years but this
incarnation of Lucifer Morningstar was
treated by Neil Diamond and first
appeared in issue 4 of a Sandman series
in 1989 before later getting his own
solo series that was written by Mike
Carey now as for loose first comic book
origin it all goes back to before the
creation of the DC Universe and Lucifer
was originally an angel known as Sam
mail and was one of two beings created
by the presence DC's version of God
basically along with his brother Michael
not together with Michael
Sammael who adopted the name Lucifer
which is Latin for light bringer because
of his ability to create stars created
the entire DC Universe as we know it
almost immediately after the creation of
the universe however Lucifer rebelled
against the presence who then sent
Lucifer to Hell where he ruled for ten
billion years alongside the demons bezel
Bob and his asel eventually however
Lucifer became frustrated with the
concept of predestination and grew bored
with ruling his kingdom and with the
stereotypes he felt were unfairly
assigned to him such as the assumption
that he forced people to do evil things
so Lucifer released all the demons and
souls from hell closed the gate and
handed the keys over to Morpheus the
title character of the Sandman series
and simply retires to earth now the list
of Lucifer's powers and abilities is
almost too long to include here since
he's a being that is nearly omnipotent
but I'm gonna try my best to get all of
them listed here of course Lucifer
possesses superhuman strength speed
durability stamina endurance agility
reflexes and senses he is immortal
having existed for billions of years as
well as practically omnipotent
omniscient and omnipresent Lucifer is
nearly invulnerable to harm and has a
regenerative healing factor for those
rare instances when he does suffer
damage he's extremely intelligent and
possesses telekinesis telepathy and
teleportation as well as pyrokinesis and
the ability to manipulate matter and
energy he's able to heal and resurrect
others and can also influence them
through temptation and hypnotism Lucifer
can fly when he's in possession of his
angel wings and can travel between
dimensions and speak and understand any
language as I'm sure I miss some here
and there but like I said he has a
nearly endless list of powers now as far
as how powerful Lucifer is he has a list
of feats that rivals his list of powers
proving he's one
of the most powerful characters in the
DC Universe just in terms of strength he
was shown to be able to throw a human
being out of Earth's gravitational pull
and into orbit
he was durable enough to survive when
his physical body was burnt to ashes and
survived a blast from his brother
Michael that was powerful enough to
destroy an entire universe Lucifer is
also fast enough to circle the planet
before an observer can detect that he's
ever left their field of vision far more
impressive than his physical feats
however are those derived from his
angelic physiology I mentioned earlier
that Lucifer got his name from his
ability to create stars but he's also
created planets in sentient life when he
creates his own universe
to rival the universe of the presence
including his own version of Earth in
Adam and Eve Lucifer is extremely
proficient at pyrokinesis and is able to
create fire strong enough to destroy an
angel and in another instance a group of
Norse Giants and one particularly
impressive feat are wounded and
significantly weakened Lucifer created
an explosion powerful enough to destroy
Fenris wolf of Norse mythology a being
that had just previously destroyed the
throne of the presence furthermore
Lucifer is able to work reality
including shrinking buildings to fit in
his hand and resurrecting a demon from a
skeleton that had long ago fossilized
he's able to take beings that exist in
dreams and conjure them into the
physical world cause immortal beings to
cease to exist and create gateways
between dimensions he's able to create
souls and place them into physical
bodies has defeated an entire pantheon
of gods that are capable of granting
reality-warping powers to every
individual on earth and killed two
immortal beings that had stolen the
omnipotence of the presence by going
back in time and blowing them up in the
past before they gained their powers
he's also capable of time-travel by the
way like I said he's basically able to
do anything he wants to do and his
widely thought to be just like the
presence at the top of the DC Universe
is power hierarchy which would
undoubtedly make him way beyond
omega-level but I want to know what you
guys think what do you guys think about
this what do you guys think about
Lucifer Morningstar in terms of the
power he possesses and what he can do I
know this video is short but I mean the
guy can do anything like how we're gonna
make a 10 minute video on a guy who can
do anything like I guess just run off a
list of all the powers that he has the
guy's insanely capable it's kind of nuts
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
who's
[Music]